You want a little update on space wars?
Well, North Korea says that they just took a picture
of the White House
with their new spy satellite.
It took them three tries,
but North Korea eventually
got a successful launch
of a spy satellite into orbit.
And the first thing they said
is, “hey, we're taking pictures
of the Pentagon
and the White House
and U.S. nuclear installations.”
We don't know if they're bluffing,
but either way, the U.S.
and their allies are pretty pissed.
But North Korea is just like,
“Hey, we have a right to
develop our weapons systems
just like you do, United States.”
This all comes at a time
when North and South Korea
had just made this agreement
to like lessen tensions
and not do things like this.
But now both sides are breaking
their agreements, there's an escalation.
This happens all the time with these two
and this is just another episode of it,
but this episode is happening in space.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.